[Musik]
ein drittel der bevölkerung
migrationshintergrund und genau die
realität muss sich in der politik
widerspiegeln das heißt dass diese
selbstverständlichkeit wird das lied
ohne migrationshintergrund hand auf sich
bringe juni bekomme ich zweiter passt so
jetzt geht's los und es ist wirklich
erstaunlich hat viele ausländische
organisationen migrantische haben mich
unterstützt aussichtlose hat ein kollege
sagt erinnerst du dich aus in die
schweiz gekommen ist haus gesagt dass
wir mit dieser gesellschaft unsere
beziehungen entwickeln sollten
was hat sie es geschafft
[Musik]
als zugewanderter interessieren mich die
wenigen gewählten migranten in der
schweizer politik
ich möchte von ihnen erfahren was sie
dazu bewogen hat sich der zeitintensiven
politik zu widmen
ich entschied mich für drei politiker
auf kantonaler ebene die als flüchtling
in die schweiz gekommen sind
durch diese erfahrung sind sie für die
politik in einer besonderen weise
sensibilisiert
[Musik]
in basel begleitet sibel arslan zu einer
groß ratssitzung
sie kam als elfjährige aus einem
kurdischen dorf in die schweiz 7 lernte
zunächst in einer sonderklasse deutsch
später studierte sie
rechtswissenschaften
[Musik]
ich besitze 2004 wollte für sie 2004
schweizer bürgerin ich habe mich lange
bürger unter kunden ich muss es
irgendwie lernen das politische system
der schweiz funktioniert und deren ich
mich erkundigen wo nicht den könnt mich
engagiere und habe mich für mini partei
basta basis stark alternative
entschieden
aber bitte keine schwitzte bis und bei
den sekretariaten gesetze
hallo ich bin aus damit nationale
mitmachen
was muss ich machen sibel ausland setzt
sich an diesem samstag für die
spielgruppenleiterinnen 1
diese seien wichtig für die
sozialisation und sprachförderung der
kinder
sie bräuchten deshalb mehr anerkennung
[Musik]
ich kann nicht christoph vorstoß
vorbereitet momentan könnte in der
verwaltung alle abteilungen der etat
dafür zuständig wäre
wo man hat auch in der partei wählen ist
aussprachen dass die strukturen
zerstören hat mir inklusive uns allen
anderen mit migrationshintergrund jorge
kostet das abstimmungsergebnis 39 39 bei
einer enthaltung und ich entscheide mich
auf ihr verstehen lassen
ein kleiner erfolg erzielt das geschäft
wird wenigstens nicht abgeschrieben
sondern weiter verfolgt group an sie war
garnison tamilische asylsuchende sitzt
seit 2006 im zuger kantonsrat seine
überraschende wahl erregte damals
schweizweit aufsehen er war der erste
farbige in einem kantons parlament
ich habe in st aber unter gymnasium
besucht und ich komme hier mit 15
das war für mich ein kulturschock eine
zeit habe gesehen schule hier ist alles
verpasst hat vorbei sozusagen mit 515
regelkreis hat hat man hier verpasst und
zweitens was mich auch zum teil traurig
gemacht hat ins lager trotz 30-jährige
bürgerkrieg ist immer noch ein
bildungsland bildung ist es immer noch
sehr wichtig und da habe ich große
großer teil der migros wie mein vater
auch waren gastronomie bereich tätig
oder im reinigungsbranche das hat mich
etwas traurig gemacht
die anwesenden politikerinnen politiker
sie sind bereit zu ihrer verteidigung
ich meine sie können die
regierungsverantwortung nur gemeinsam
und sie werden das sage ich jetzt als
katholischer pfarrer die hilfe des
heiligen geistes
die hilfe des geistes jesu christi der
uns vom vater gesandt wurde
sie werden diese hilfe brauchen können
es ist für mich als frisch gewählt durch
atoms ratspräsidenten eine große ehre
und ein bewegendes erlebnis in diesem
gotteshaus mit der vereidigung meine
erste amtshandlung vorzunehmen
gibt es sie gesetzlich cartoons like
mitglieder und regierungsrats mitglieder
die stufen zu erheben und mir die worte
ich schwöre es nach zu sprechen ich
schwöre es
[Musik]
ich glaube schon erwähnt die vorne dabei
eine neue farbe und raum und ist eine
bereicherung für den zuger kantonsrat
bringt lebensnahe vorstellte ich finde
auch dass für die migration migration
das gute siegt auch leute die zu uns
gekommen sind sie sicher verschiedene
die politik einsteigen damit neben nach
einem bremer gruppen in einer
hinduistischen familie aufgewachsen
möchte kirche und politik strikt trennen
er lässt sich mit wenigen anderen im
rathaus verteidigen
group als polit karriere begann im
kantonsrat bei den grün alternativen
er wurde jedoch sechs jahre später
überraschend aus der fraktion
ausgeschlossen
heute ist keiner mehr will ich über
diesen konflikt zu sprechen
schließlich arbeiten sie im rat wieder
zusammen nach anhörung beider seiten
hatte ich den eindruck dass es wohl die
konkurrenz mit anderen
fraktionsmitgliedern war die zu diesem
ausschluss führte interessant dabei war
dass die partei den ausschluss des
einzigen migranten gegen aussen lange
nicht kommunizierte weil keine als
fremdenfeindlich gelten wollte heute ist
man bei der sp
pazzini mangalore u bahn kam als kind
aus sri lanka in die schweiz
die gelernte krankenschwester arbeitet
das team leiterin in einem pflegeheim
sie erwirtschaftet das haupteinkommen
der familie und unterstützt ihren mann
bei seiner politischen arbeit dankt man
hintergrund habe ich vielleicht ein
anderer blickwinkel
ich betrachte vieles anders und ich habe
die gewisse lebenserfahrung ich weiß
etwas was ein flüchtling sein was es in
schwierigkeiten glied ich weiß es wenn
man in diese gesellschaft sprache nicht
beherrscht was sind die schwierigkeiten
seine motivation für die politik
schöpfte aus der eigenen erfahrung sein
berufliche einstieg war alles andere als
einfach sehr lange suchtrupp an eine
lehrstelle bisher dank vermittlung einer
schweizerin eine als drucker fand zur
zeit studierte er an der fachhochschule
für soziale arbeit in luzern
eines wusste wann genau er wollte nicht
das ganze berufsleben in der küche
arbeiten wie viele tamilen
er hatte andere ziele und suchte
kontakte außerhalb der gemeinschaft
seiner landsleute
ich habe integrative vereine ausgesucht
integrativ organisation da sind
schweizer und schweizerinnen drin da
sind alban und winter sind
afghan und iraner ist wirklich gemischte
gruppe und da diskutieren wir hier was
fällt es uns was müssen wir machen
china ist einer der wenigen migranten
der ersten generation in der schweizer
politik aus der kurve vor über 30 jahren
in die schweiz flüchtete erkannte er
früh dass er über den kreis der
landsleute hinaus kontakte suchen sollte
er sitzt seit drei jahren im
kantonsparlament für das grüne bündnis
zuvor war er sechs jahre im
stadtparlament bern
ich treffe ihn im büro von pro infirmis
wo er als bereichsleiter tätig ist
sofort anfangen was nicht wollten sofort
anfangen und auch wenn misserfolge
vorkommen wiederum weiter vorn
dranbleiben weiterfahren daran breiten
wie war sein eigener weg der weg war
lang und steinig vor allem am anfang war
es sehr schwierig in einem sein werden
der sprachkenntnisse vor allem
deutschkenntnisse konnte ein bisschen
französisch und auf der anderen seite
qualifikationen und fähigkeiten die man
mitgenommen hat die hier nicht gültig
waren wenn man so sagen darf
kumpel fasching sanya ist mit annemarie
verheiratet das paar hat zwei erwachsene
söhne die studieren
annamarie sanya war acht jahre im berner
stadtparlament anja amtierte sie als
höchste bernerin wie beurteilt sie den
politischen werdegang ihres mannes
erfahrung gemacht von diskriminierung
von auch ausgrenzung bis dann kommen die
dinge die wirklich ich glaube lebens
prägend sind was wichtig ist ist dass er
seine politik immer wieder auf die frage
diskriminierung grundrechte rechte für
alle zurück spiegelt was er auch in
welchen themen er auch aktiv ist hat der
grundlegende eine grundlegende haltung
wie eine art folie oder master in dem er
seine politischen forderungen wie die
spieler zeit es jetzt finanzpolitik sei
dass sozialpolitik dass er sie im
innenraum soziale gerechtigkeit
letztendlich geht und da glaube ich ist
der viel konsequenter als viele
politiker und das ist in jeder sparte
ein neues passieren und er hätte am 2
die kräfte und würde ich die sich jede
klasse wollen wie lange sie dauern
das sind nur so da
damit in seinen ersten jahren in der
schweiz interessiert der hasch in sanya
was in der türkei politisch geschah er
kämpfte vor allem gegen die
menschenrechtsverletzungen in seiner
heimat heute setzt er sich aber auch für
die sozial schwachen und für
umweltthemen in der schweiz ein
[Musik]
es ist immer schön keine guten morgen
interesse der menschen mit behinderung
wunderschön
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fasching sanya hat mit organisiert dass
vertreter der behindertenorganisationen
den frisch gewählten schweizerischen
nationalratspräsidenten stéphane rossini
besuchen können
sie wollen ihn auf die anliegen der
menschen mit behinderung aufmerksam
machen
ganz herzlichen dank dass ich heute uns
akzeptiert haben unter sie musste
zeitweise agiert haben ich weiß es sind
sehr beschäftigt und unter hartz debatte
ist sehr anspruchsvoll
es würde uns freuen weil sie das im
nationalrat stellen verteilen lassen
würden aber sie entscheiden guten block
1 bis
ich bin sehr froh dass sie ihr gekommen
seid das ist für mich sehr wichtig als
sozialpolitiker bin ich sehr bewusst
dass die die menschen mit behinderung ja
viele schwierigkeiten im leben abend
deshalb müssen wir uns immer als
politiker engagieren
was war seine eltern sagen würden wenn
sie ihn mit dem höchsten schweizer
gesehen hätten
gut gemacht hast du dich für die
anliegen der menschen mit einer
behinderung einsetzt
vielleicht auch ein stück stolz
aber vielleicht auch ein bisschen
behinderungen das dass man mit dem
höchsten schweizer ein termin
vereinbaren kann und mit ihm auch wenn
es ein kurzes gespräch ist dass man
zusammenkommt und über eine und
diskutiert sibel arslan ist gradlinig
spricht auch dass unangenehme an sie
werde immer wieder massiv angegriffen
sagt sie
so zum beispiel ende november 2014
sie hätte leiterin der straf und
massnahmenvollzugs im kanton baselland
werden sollen sie machte unter 30
bewerbern das rennen
der vertrag war schon unterschrieben
aber es kam alles anders und rechte das
ganze marktmacht der fünf tage
hintereinander ohne dass ich dazu
ständig nahm aufgrund von ihnen
betrieben oder aufgrund sodann betrieb
des stroms zur kampagne gemacht und dann
aber entschieden dass jetzt stellen
mittwoch
fakt ist dass gegen aslan betreibung
liefen wegen bürgschaften und wegen
einem unternehmen aus ihrer
studentenzeit
tatsache ist aber auch dass innert
wochenfrist alle betreibungen erledigt
wurden wie sie im bewerbungsgespräch
ihrem zukünftigen vorgesetzten
versprochen hatte der journalist holte
das nicht zur kenntnis nehmen und sich
nicht zur sache jedenfalls in oaxaca iss
transportieren strom überhaupt nichts
dran ist
schulte nachhilfe bezahlen raten das
kurz vorm abschluss zurückzahlen und
drehten die tagespauschale von der ganze
schuld
die spekulationen der basler zeitung
würden sämtliche grundlagen entbehren
sagte der grüne baselbieter
regierungsrat und siebels vorgesetzter
isaac reber den medien die zeitung
spreche von schulden von über 60000
franken
tatsächlich seien es lediglich rund 5000
aufgrund der tagelangen negativen
berichterstattung sei das vertrauen in
der bevölkerung aber zerstört worden
deshalb könne sie die stelle nicht
antreten die öffentlichkeit hatte sich
mit falschen fakten eine meinung
gebildet
sibel arslan selbst hat sich lange nicht
öffentlich geäußert weil es mit ihrem
vorgesetzten so abgesprochen war eine
anfrage für ein interview ließ
regierungsrat reber unbeantwortet
ich fühle mich erinnere schwebe ich
schmerzen noch klar es ist schön dass
jetzt das gefühl haben muss man einfach
eine landung redet muss man ihn so fest
über schulden und finanziell auf album
in rhede muss man eine person nacht eine
stelle finde ich ganz schlimm mit
migrationshintergrund jetzt
selbstverständliche große rolle spielt
ich bin der betreuung
ich bin ein vorbild
die zeit der vakanz hat der fahrer eines
schweizer mal etwas mehr passiert ist
ist passiert
zum zeitpunkt meiner recherche waren von
15 kantonalen politiker mit
migrationshintergrund nur zwei in einer
bürgerlichen partei
diese kamen aber nicht als flüchtling in
die schweiz migranten fanden bisher eher
bei linken gehört für eine nationale
karriere die sie anstreben hört der
migranten bonus auch bei den linken auf
ich traf im bundeshaus die luzerner
ärztin yvette estermann die seit 2007
für die schweizerische volkspartei im
bundeshaus politisiert wie hat sie in
der svp die nicht eben eine migrations
freundliche politik betreibt in so
kurzer zeit den weg nach oben geschafft
das weiß ich nicht
es ist dass das ist die frau dachte
immer in der luft das ein fehler war
mich schon fragt ein
ich weiß es nicht ich bin immer zu
sachstand bei mir diesen hier um
irgendwie persönlich sich für die
westermann kam 1994 durch die heirat mit
einem schweizer aus der slowakei nach
kriens bei luzern
trotz nachfragen kann sie keine
konkreten gründe für ihren
karrieresprung nennen ihre schnelle
polit karriere scheint ein einzigartiger
aufstieg zu sein
sie seien nicht von hier
das ist nicht nur dass das gut über alle
parteien wird sagen dass gott durch
ganze bevölkerung dass einige sagt ja
ausgerechnet du warum westumfahrung
politik überhaupt es sind die meinige
wollen der bevölkerung sind dass sich
migranten haben wir genannter viele
seite zurückhaltende einrichtung der
bevölkerung hat ausländische wurzeln
und es ist arzner dass man sich langsam
aber sicher dass wir auch politische
ämter irgend einmal ein drittel
mythen um zweiter oder dritter
generation in der schweiz sind und das
ist das ist mini mini schätzung und ich
bin überzeugt dass es auch gut und ich
muss eigentlich sagen ich bin ja
freiwillig insel antrag und das war
natürlich ganz anders wenn ich ein
poster flüchten und da bin ich einfach
dankbar dafür
rufen sie war ghanesen besucht mit
seinen eltern in rubigen bern eine
hinduistische beisetzungstermin ii die
geräumige mehrzweckhalle eignet sich für
die vielen menschen die aus der ganzen
schweiz angereist sind sie wollen einer
verstorbenen familien die letzte ehre
erweisen
sosehr rupp an sie war ghanesen die
teilnahme der migranten am politischen
geschehen in der schweiz fördert pflegt
er dennoch auch seine kulturellen
wurzeln
er will seine herkunft nicht vergessen
[Musik]
als letztes jahr meiner großmutter
gestorben ist slomka war ich auch dort
ich habe wunderschöne gefunden wie man
von einem mensch sich verabschiedet dort
haben sie jeden tag das gekocht was sie
gern gegessen hat das ist hier in
ähnlicher weise nicht möglich dass man
an der situation genau so zu machen wie
ihn so lange arbeite hier versucht man
nach dieser gewisse rituale gewisse
harmonie beibehaltung
falls gut da
[Musik]
sibel arslan trifft im innenhof des
basler grossrat diebe görgl ii welche
seit kurzem im grossrat politisiert
beide haben in der schweiz gute
ausbildung absolviert und sind
mehrsprachig das sind kompetenzen die
ihnen selbstbewusstsein verleihen
[Musik]
basel spielt eine vorreiterrolle im
grossrat sitzen sieben personen aus der
türkei mehrheitlich kurdisch
alevitischer herkunft auch ein
fdp-mitglied ist dabei dank ihrer arbeit
hat basel stadt das einziger kanton in
der schweiz
die aleviten eine offene
glaubensrichtung des islam als
religionsgemeinschaft anerkannt wenn ich
in einem ort lebe ich kann ja nichts
zuschauer und lebenslang quasi meinem
umfeld passiert interessiert mich direkt
also ich kann nicht nach 40 jahren in
diesem land leben und dann sagen ja ich
bin mein haus lernen demokratie ist
gesund werden alle gesellschafts teilen
mitmachen der türkei diskriminierung
erlebt dass ausländerfeindlichkeit oder
sich irgendwie es so wichtig dass das
auch endlich und jugendlich weil ich
mich sozialen netzwerken mit viel die
heimische aber wenn ich jetzt hört mit
36 jahre alt als frau in der wirtschaft
als mutter und politisch engagiert und
neu hintergrund ausländische wurzeln
endlich wird filme diskriminiert muss
ich früher noch nicht kennt kann eine
hand mit vielen sehr viel lytro in der
privatwirtschaft sehr etablierte chips
hat also das sind vor gesundheitswesen
bis irgendwo und freue mich im
gesundheitsweisen ich wüsste nicht was
gesundheitswesen migranten wird machen
weil die leicht erhöhte sehr sehr guten
job und wieso nicht in der verwaltung
integration das ist also dort haben wir
also die die leute die katholische sind
nicht mit land und mir war das so lang
bringen reicht die themen bis liegt das
nur eine höhere und bis es einfach
eigentlich mal getroffen ist das schwer
bitte frau stimmrechten heute sagt auf
messe bringen wünsche für unserer
wählerschaft zum parlament gesperrt ist
eine partei könne bringe wird die
mehrere verschiedene partei vertreten
sie das nicht nur der woche habe die
grüne und sp sondern auch betrieben für
mich jetzt betreff gefehlt und warum
nicht cvp und svp
wenn die sp sagt die umweltpolitik ist
für uns sehr wichtig dafür haben wir für
die umweltpolitik jemand in bern oder
sozialpolitik ist für uns wichtig im
bären im parlament haben wie jemand der
für uns sozialpolitik macht dann wenn
sie dann behaupten die migrationspolitik
oder die integration oder die zugezogene
sind auch für uns wichtig denn sie
sollen auch in bergen von diesen leuten
etwas haare also hier macht aber es geht
eher um das ob sie unsere themen ernst
nehmen als die glocke läutet einen alle
zu einer abstimmung der glanz gilt dass
eine der migranten in der politik
gefördert hat was sagt er zu dieser
kritik halte die einschätzung nicht also
man spürt schon sehr vielen
interessengruppen dass die erwartungen
höher sind als das was man anbieten kann
jetzt beim ausländerstimmrecht ich weiß
dass wir in basel eine initiative
lanciert haben wir haben sie brutal
verloren sogar in basel
und dann ist es halt schwierig also es
ist manchmal nicht nur eine frage ob man
etwas will sondern auch ob man etwas
schafft man etwas kann wir haben so
viele migranten die angesprochen werden
muss müssen sei dass in der bildung in
der in der gesundheits- oder in der
sicherheitspolitik und da macht es
völlig sehen dass eben nach mehr
migranten
der verwaltung setzen für mich ist das
allerwichtigste dass die migranten
selber sich in die politik einmischen
niemand kann das so glaubwürdig
vertreten wie sie selbst und dieses
anliegen habe ich immer immer vertreten
es ist ganz wichtig dass die parteien
diese migranten auf die listen nehmen
und dass sie ihnen die möglichkeit geben
dass sie gewählt werden können
cem atan akquisitionsziel conseil d'etat
rost us-kollegen kollegen stabile
lebensverhältnisse und eine umfassende
integration der wohnbevölkerung sind ein
guter maßstab für den wert den die
politik der sozialen sicherheit gibt
sicherheit nicht mehr ausgaben von
militärs solidarität mit den schwächeren
mitglieder der gesellschaft das vergesse
ich auch dass ich ja ein migrant bin und
ich bin andere kolleginnen kollegen oder
gegner und und gegnerin aber macht man
dann erinnert man sich selber porto wird
es dann auch in die erinnerung gebracht
indirekt wenn man dann angesprochen wird
und so weit wenn es macht man dann
diskussion auf französisch gibt dort
vergesse ich auch das sieht ein
migranten gegenüber beiden teilen habe
ich dort den vorteil dass sie die
französische sprache viel besser als
viele anderen beherrsche fasching sanya
ist ein erfolgreiches ratsmitglied das
gute an der politischen arbeit sei dass
er mit verschiedenen leuten im selben
saal setzte und die menschen sich hier
kennen lernen
auch wenn sie verschiedene politische
ansichten vertreten
so könne eine annäherung über die
persönliche beziehung stattfinden
der mensch ist ein soziales wesen die
beziehung entwickeln austauschen weil
von diesem austausch lernt man auch
schon einander die gesellschaft ändert
sich ja auch immer geschlossen
nach der groß ratssitzung gehen haschem
sanya und sein ratskollege fritz ruchti
von der svp zu einem gemeinsamen
mittagessen
sie schätzen aneinander vor allem die
offenheit und ehrlichkeit
ihr habt das ist auch vom publikum mit
der typischen schweizer beruf soll ich
im flachland als ein sehr land nicht
gemäß bezieht sondern allgemein
diese abgetreten oder sie ist ein titel
beim ursprünglichen aber meine familie
auch eigentlich bauen und es war selbst
versorgen und gesagt zwischen 20 bis 30
leute eigentlich die von diesem bottom
line geld haben aber gut unter den augen
des hofes von butter käse die kartoffeln
und 7 und tomas kopecky schweiz zu gast
das lokal wieder sie zu beschreiben sie
ihr geld einer islamisten von den
extremisten
es ist dein gesprächen zusammen
es ist schwierig so viel wie sonst auch
der kritik lässt und der frau geriet
wieder sieht das verrückte situation die
dimension der gewalt durch die
dschihadisten macht auch hasch in sanya
sprachlos aus eingewanderten bewegt er
sich in zwei welten ein vorteil
welche nachteile hat aber sein
migrationshintergrund in der politik
wenn man die geschichtliche entwicklung
nicht miterlebt hat man kann natürlich
lesen und so weiter aber wenn jemand das
miterlebt hat hat ein anderer
erinnerungsvermögen aus wenn man das
gelesen bereitet aber auch sprachen zum
teil auch ein thema weil das schnell
geht und man schnell reagieren muss und
eben auch in schriftlichen sehr
fehlerfrei sein spruch wesentlichen teil
von der politische arbeit und mit alles
wenig denn die arbeit machen
in der ende türkische organisationen
vereine oder kurdische verein und
aleviten vereine und so weiter dort
öffneten diese rolle sondern türkische
und kurdische wesentliche rolle da sich
denn das was da in der schweiz basiert
auf die mutter spruch erklären
in der politik im rot ist das natürlich
wichtig dass man den spruch beherrscht
ich glaube ich hat der vorteil des
troubled schritt für mich ist einfach
der inhalt ist wichtig was bringe ich
als inhalt sind diese inhalte nicht
irgendwie keiner seiner hand und fuß
gibt es muss einfach die inhalt muss das
für mich stimmen nachher was diese genau
unter prozent dramatisch stimmt oder
nicht dass ich für mich jetzt konnte
obwohl ich jetzt schon über 20 jahre
dabei und ich denke auch im die aber
sind gebe es im moment vor allem sehr
emotionell im moment wo man einfach
umschaltet und denkt wenn ich das jetzt
in meiner muttersprache
die seite werde das viel besser wie der
andere
was haben meine gesprächspartner in
ihrer mehrjährigen politischen karriere
erreicht mich erreicht dass die meisten
migranten migranten im kanton
basel-stadt sich vor die politische
ereignis interessiere
insbesondere die türkei mit kutcher
hintergrund hintergrund ab damit sie
sind in basel sehr aktiv durch dass das
mehr ein fall waren die raten musst du
schaden als ich also in der schweiz wenn
man das gesetzlich verändern will
das dauert lange zum beispiel ich meinen
sprach motionen habe ich 2007
eingereicht im parlament um das fahren
krise diskussion und jetzt 2013/14 ist
als gesetz verankert also das heißt es
braucht so viel habe nur für ein gesetz
fasching sanya besucht den verein kult
tisch in bern die politischen
entwicklungen in der schweiz seien für
einige seiner landsleute zu komplex
sagte er mir
es sei aber auch für viele schweizer
schwierig diese inhalte zu verstehen
[Musik]
während jj könnte gehen bei seinem
referat vor wenigen besuchern während
der für die umgestaltung des berner
breitenrain platzes
[Musik]
die schweiz ist bezüglich des
ausländerstimmrecht deutlich strenger
als vergleichbare länder
die folge ist dass gemäss untersuchungen
das interesse der zugewanderten für die
politik tiefer ist astas der
einheimischen
[Musik]
ich schwitze oder schweizerin bekommt
ihr in der regel wenn sie 18 sind
stimmen unterlage wahlunterlagen und
wird es dann irgendwann einmal natürlich
also dass bürger und bürgerinnen der
trichter oder verantwortung mit der
person dem wohn und beteiligt sich dann
fatal und generale ein migrant oder
migrantinnen wurde die unterlagen nicht
wo und was ich da gar nichts bringen
oder interessieren warum auch immer ein
warum soll ich jetzt als das ganze
irgendwo her dass ich hier überhaupt
gehört wird das meiste hat interessiert
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er hat ein
[Applaus]
alverskirchen kenntnis dass der report
gar keiner
wer gibt sie will das land die stimme
ich muss wirklich machen
es sind einfach sehr viel party und
vertreiber aus sie war einfach auf
schweizer und schweizerinnen kunde hand
es müsste jetzt einfach damit grund und
migranten in der politik sie es müsste
junge leute in der politik sind es
müsste mehr frauen in der politik
sibel arslan ist in basel zu hause ihre
ganze familie und der freundeskreis
leben hier
vor einem auftritt trifft sie ihre
freundin elli fiel der in seinem kaffee
[Musik]
sondern befinden
ich bin
[Musik]
sie will ausland ist eine gefragte
podiums teilnehmerin hier im forum für
zeitfragen diskutiert sie mit bekannten
persönlichkeiten über die zukunft der
stadt basel herzlich willkommen
die damen und herren in folge zum
längsten ober vertrag in basel
bevor ich wieder schweiz gibt es so viel
lieber gar kein buch in dem konzert
tragen können mitmachen
das sind alte russland wo sie zehn
jahren baute lernen und trainer mit
bestimmten thema nie trainieren ich bin
das wichtigste für mich ist eine chance
gleich halten dass man auf augenhöhe
begegnet und kessler muss klose vom
konzert einstimmen oder keine
möglichkeit die stimmung nichts bringe
sehen sie das auch so
das ist tatsächlich so also 196 menschen
und behinderte hand stimm und wahlrecht
und nutzte kurz knapp die hälfte
das heißt es sind ja die wahl der
abstimmung über 50 liegt wo politik
machen dort und dann ist fifty fifty das
heißt mehrheit winter sind 26 wenn der
kanton verhoben
vor der wohnung ein einsehen und das ist
die demokratie das ist sie als eltern
großeltern mit den augen der herbstritt
und konfessionsfreie mit vorurteil die
grässliche sie sehen dass wir heute
einen ausland im land kultivieren
und weil man dir ehrlichkeit migrant
entsprechen und im moment gern haus und
liegt somit können wir auch differenzen
besser erkennen und mit anderen und das
ich bin ich sage immer von integration
und inklusion reden anführer mit einer
homogenen bilden ihre story von chris
melzer das ist dort wo soziale
beziehungen
[Musik]
die erste chance
sportlich
meine heimat ist
ich bin hier verwurzelt ich denke unsere
heimat ist hier wird es wieder hier
bleiben
[Musik]
ja
gruppe was sind die häufigen machen hat
man ihn im kanton zug land wien müller
mal hier was kannst du besser machen als
ein herr müller oder ein hermann gute
frage
ich frage mich einfach ob man das da
diesen namen gerichten soll
ich habe genau gleich 1600 gramm gehirn
wie alle anderen möglichen funktioniert
da so und natürlich vielleicht
hintergrund ist etwas anderes
aber es ist schade dass man auf diesen
namen fokussiert aber ich meine im zug
ich bin irgendwie erster farbiger mensch
überhaupt in zwei parlament gewählt
wurde
das hat ja gesagt diese offenheit aber
trotzdem wenn es um somit zb diese
diskussion gibt wenn also eine
leitstelle geht zu ändern der name da
diese person hat man mir
[Applaus]
mit trauern hier und heute um die
hunderten von verstorbenen vor lampedusa
wir trauern hier und heute um die
tausende von ertrunkenen im mittelmeer
[Musik]
aber
fasching st an der demonstration am
weltfrauentag
ich fragte den engagierten
sozialpolitiker ob es einfach sei eine
gerechte gesellschaft zu erreichen
ja das ist eine philosophische frage was
ist gerecht
aber ich denke es ist gerecht dass man
eine gerechte gesellschaft verlangt dass
man eine solidarische gesellschaft
verlangt wie viel man erreichen kann das
ist eine andere frage
die traumpaar uns oder unsere verfassung
sagte die stärke der gesellschaft muss
sich an wohlbefinden der schwächsten und
ich denke das ist ein motto das wird uns
als beispiel nehmen slot
[Musik]
sibel arslan in der bar ihres bruders
die familiäre bindung sei sehr stark
sagt sie sehr glücklich
ich habe zwei bretter ich behaupte immer
wieder das sind die tollste breitere
dass die jetzt gibt verschnitt
unterscheiden zwischen zuvor
man wusste nicht
[Musik]
von den acht millionen menschen in der
schweiz sind rund 3 millionen ausländer
und eingebürgerte in den regierungen
parlamenten in der verwaltung und den
gerichten dort wo vieles entschieden
wird bildet sich dieser realität aber
nicht ab die schweiz und die migranten
haben einen großen nachholbedarf
[Musik]
dann werde ich glaube ich bin sehr
authentisch und das was ich verdreht
vertrete ich fest überzeugt
und insofern wird in denen themen aber
nicht immer wieder dazu geäußert haben
ernst genommen
[Musik]
alle beim kleinkunst in kraft
unter dem strich
das eine grab
[Musik]
ich mache dass ich irgendwann mal als
schweizer politikerin erachtet wird und
nicht als politiker mit
migrationshintergrund und in der
schublade
denn das ist mir sehr wichtig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in den beschenkten herrn den beschwerden
[Musik]
und dafür bekommt
links
ich dachte
[Applaus]
der 4
[Musik]